[Musique]
le Salon de l'Agriculture une belle
vitrine pour les agriculteurs chaque
année le département des Yvelines invite
plus d'une dizaine de producteurs du
territoire cette année ils étaient 10 à
se relayer sur le stand du département
c'est une chance énorme qu'on nous offre
même si on a 2 mètres carrés c'est et
c'est énorme on a été invité par le
département des Yvelines pour
représenter les producteurs yvelinois
l'avantage c'est qu'on puisse avoir une
belle vitrine au niveau du salon parmi
les enjeux majeurs du département
favoriser les initiatives locales et
développer les circuits courts une
collaboration a été mise en place avec
les Hauts-de-Seine pour favoriser la
consommation locale notamment dans les
collèges nous avons en commun d'essayer
de développer tout ce qui est
agroalimentaire et en particulier de
développer les circuits courts pour
permettre à nos collégiens que que ce
soit dans le 92 ou dans le 78 d'accéder
à des produits qui étaient qui ont été
cultivés dans le département des
Yvelines autre acteur en soutien aux
agriculteurs l'île de France et l'Europe
elles investissent chaque année 20
millions d'euros pour les agriculteurs
franciliens on accompagne les
agriculteurs aussi bien sur
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
parce que c'est un enjeu essentiel le
renouvellement des générations on va
aider à la transmission des
exploitations et on est on aide aussi
les agriculteurs sur tout ce qui est
investissement donc c'est la
construction de hangar l'ouverture de
boutiques à la ferme et puis aussi
maintenant depuis quelques années l'aide
au changement climatique pour un projet
d'investissement si je prends par
exemple un investissement productif donc
par exemple un nouvel outil de
production qui permet de faire mieux des
biscuits de faire mieux des cookies on
peut avoir des aides qui sont comprises
entre 30 et 50% du financement donc
c'est non négligeable et c'est aussi une
forme de garantie pour les banques les
Yvelines abritent plus de 3000 emplois
directs dans le secteur agricole et
16000 emplois indirects dans le secteur
agroalimentaire